the conservative political action
conference is one part political
carnival
one part serious policy discussion and
with russia now invading ukraine u.s
policy on that conflict took center
stage no matter where you stand on this
ukraine russia situation what we should
have done beforehand what we should do
now the one thing i think everyone can
agree upon
is that the people of ukraine are
inspiring to the world
for many republicans it's also a chance
to bash president joe biden
mike pompeo the republican secretary of
state under president donald trump said
his old boss would have handled it
better how did we prevail it was peace
through strength it was reagan's model
it was the model that we used for four
years in the trump administration we put
america first and we told people around
the world
you cannot tread on us
the former president's impeachment over
charges he withheld nearly 400 million
dollars in military aid to ukraine was
not mentioned since 1974 the
conservative political action conference
has been home to die hard conservatives
mostly foreign policy hawks that changed
under president donald trump who had a
more non-interventionist policy and a
notoriously close relationship with
vladimir putin that's why a lot of
people here say the invasion of ukraine
would not have happened under trump i
think that it would have been different
because he had a better understanding of
how to communicate with putin and let
him understand that we as the united
states are the lead the world's leading
power and that we would not accept such
bad actors
but you'd prefer to have president trump
dealing with this yes
100 000
because it's leadership
trump won't be here to put his own spin
on it until late saturday but reminders
of the 45th president are everywhere
here where in the minds of many
attendees he is still president john
hendren al jazeera orlando florida